Open up the Developer API Guide
for Settings, if you want to follow along.
If you've pondered it carefully
and you've decided
you really want this to be a setting,
this is what you do next.
Android provides a way
to display a hierarchy of preferences,
including headers,
such as the ones shown here.
The value of the preference
is called the preference summary,
and that's seen here.
It looks almost like the subtitle text.
The preference also provides UI
to allow users to modify that setting.
You just need to supply the strings,
but you don't have to implement the UI
like the spinner here.
Common preference types
are the check box preference,
list preference, edit text preference.
We can see some examples
in the settings app
under developer options.
Here's a bunch of preferences.
This is an example
of a check box preference.
This is an example of a list preference
where you have different
radio button options here.
Once the user changes the setting,
it gets saved in the default share
preferences file.
This stores a bunch of key value pairs
of primitive data.
An example integer preference could be
how many days of e-mail history
should be saved locally on the device.
You could have a string
stored integer preferences
for what the currently selected account
and device is. Then at any time
you can fetch the value
of this shared preferences,
as long as you pass in
the name of the key that you want.
You can also use shared preferences
outside the context of settings as well.
This information is located
in the developer API guide,
for storage options,
which is also linked below.